Hi everyone.
Today I'm going to talk about
Bernoulli process practice
number one.
In this problem, you are
visiting a rain forest.
But unfortunately you have run
out of insect repellent.
As a result, the probability of
you getting mosquito bites
is really high.
At each second, the probability
that a mosquito
will land on your neck is 0.5.
If a mosquito lands on your
neck, the probability that it
will bite you is 0.2.
And the probability that it will
never bother you is 0.8.
All of this happens
independently among all
mosquitoes.
For part A of the problem, we're
interested in finding
the expected value of the time
between successive mosquito
bites and the variance of the
time between successive
mosquito bites.
From the problem statement we
know that the probability
distributions of getting
mosquito bites at different
times are identically
distributed and independent.
Therefore, the mosquito bites
occur as a Bernoulli process
with parameter p, where p
represents the probability of
getting a mosquito bite
at each second.
And p can be calculated as the
probability that a mosquito
lands on your neck at each
second multiplied by the
probability that a mosquito will
bite you, given that it
has landed on your neck.
And this is equal to 0.5 times
0.2, which is equal to 0.1.
Next let us define x as the
time between successive
mosquito bites.
Because of the memory-less
property of the Bernoulli
process, which means the
probability of getting
mosquito bites at different
times are independent, x is
equivalent to the time until
the next mosquito bite.
And x is a geometrical
random variable whose
PMF is like the following.
For all x, let's say equal
to 0, the probabilities
are equal to 0.
For x equal to 1, the
probability that it takes 1
second to the next mosquito
bite is simply equal to p.
And for x equal to 2, the
probability that it takes 2
seconds until the next mosquito
bite is equal to 1
minus p times p.
And for x equal to 3, the
probability that it takes 3
seconds until the next mosquito
bite is equal to 1
minus p to the power
of 2 times p.
Similarly, for x equal to k, the
probability that it takes
k seconds until the next
mosquito bite is equal to 1
minus p to the power of
k minus 1 times p.
Therefore the expected value
of x is equal to 1 over p,
which is equal to 1 over 0.1,
which is equal to 10.
And the variance of x is equal
to 1 minus p over p squared,
which is equal to 1 minus 0.1
over 0.1 squared, which is
equal to 90.
For part B of the problem,
we're considering
another type of bug.
Similar to the case as the
mosquitoes, here at each
second the probability that a
tick will land on your neck is
equal to 0.1.
And if a tick lands on your
neck, the probability that it
will bite you is equal to 0.7.
And the probability that
it will never bother
you is equal to 0.3.
And all this happens
independently among all ticks
and all mosquitoes.
So similar to the case as part
A, where mosquito bites occurs
as a Bernoulli process with
parameter p equal to 0.1, here
the tick bites also across
a Bernoulli process with
parameter q equal to 0.1 times
0.7, which is equal to 0.07.
And q is the probability
of getting a tick
bite at each second.
Therefore, the bug bites occurs
as a merged process
from the mosquito bites
and the tick bites.
And let r represent the
parameter for the bug bites.
So here r is equal to the
probability of getting either
a mosquito bite or
a tick bite.
And this is equivalent to 1
minus the probability of
getting no mosquito bite
and no tick bite.
Because the mosquito bites and
the tick bites happens
independently, therefore this
can be written as 1 minus the
probability of no mosquito bites
times the probability of
no tick bites at each second.
And this is equal to 1 minus p
times 1 minus q, which is p
plus q minus pq, which is equal
to 0.1 plus 0.7 minus
0.1 times 0.7.
Which is equal to 0.163.
Next, let us define y
as the time between
successive bug bites.
So similar as x in part a,
here y is a geometric
distribution with parameter r.
And therefore the expected value
of y is equal to 1 over
r, which is equal
to 1 over 0.163.
That is approximately 6.135.
And the variance of y is equal
to 1 minus r over r squared,
which is equal to 1 minus 0.163
over 0.163 squared.
And this is approximately
31.503.
So this gives us the expected
value of the time between
successive bug bites and the
variance of the time between
successive bug bites.
And this concludes our
two days practice
on Bernoulli process.